our great friend who kicks things off
here every single day on nbc sports on
peacock
is now if i'm not mistaken
less than a month away
from the debut of his book where all
books are acquired pre-order it right
now on amazon
and other spots where books can be
acquired the author of playmakers
is mike florio back here on the rich
eisen show how are you mike three weeks
and six days until i find out that no
one has purchased it
that's not true man that's not true
that's not you had to order more hey
from the printer that's great news
by the way those are words i never heard
when i put my book out in 2007 which can
be acquired where all books are
purchased from one sentence
do you really yes i do in my library
i still do
well thank you for being one of the few
sir thank you for that um
we have about a hundred that's just
stupid
stop it yes we do have many of them here
uh okay mike florio what is the story
coming out of the super bowl that
intrigues you the most what do you got
for me well i think it's the
the out of the blue combo platter of
maybe sean mcvay hitting the road maybe
aaron donald calling it quits and the
possibility that both men are and i
fully support them if this is the case
trying to get staying cronky as i said
yesterday on pf tpm to pull out the big
george costanza wallet
and start peeling off bills he doesn't
have coupons in there for a free save
the tiger poster at an exxon in
florida he's got cash and we saw the
cash on display i saw his boat it was
down in the arena from where we were
staying it's a big ass boat so uh it's
time to start paying these guys and if
i'm sean mcvay
see what
espn wants to do see what anybody else
wants to do make me an offer and there's
nothing wrong with him taking that offer
to stan kroenke and saying look they're
offering me this you're paying me that
you want me to stay you want to keep
working at this capacity
uh then you got to do something about it
and i think from aaron donald's
perspective he's due to make 18 million
in change each of the next three years
if they want him to not retire
they need to take care of him and i and
there's nothing wrong with that these
guys turn their lives over
to the pursuit
of the the mountain they climbed on
sunday they give up so much of
themselves
and it generates a ton of money for
cronky and for the organization and it's
only fair for them to expect their fair
share well there's no cap on what you
can pay mcvay what what what what's the
deal with donald's contract is that
stuff not guaranteed uh those those
dollars or or what what can they do on
that front that can make aaron donald
say you know what maybe playing the 35
is a better idea he's passed the
guaranteed portion of the deal the
question is just raw dollars 18 million
a year and change when the top of the
market's 27 and a half million i think
joey boses still got the high end and
this guy's a transcendent player and by
the time this contract's up
he's going to be in a spot where you
know he's going to inevitably start to
decline especially when you consider the
pounding he's taken and maybe this is a
oh i don't want to say jim brown because
jim brown stepped away to go to
hollywood but i remember when robert
smith retired after the 2000 season it
was just like hey i want to walk away
while i can still walk and you look at
the pounding that aaron donald takes
constantly with two and three guys
trying to keep him from wreaking havoc
at a certain point it's got to take a
toll and the other thing too
hey
he's a pittsburgh guy
and
you're in la five months out of the year
when you're a pittsburgh guy and and i i
flew from pittsburgh to l.a and nine
days later from la to pittsburgh and
it's like getting on a rocket ship not
an airplane that's how different the two
places are and uh you know i'm not
saying he's he's he wants to be traded
but it's just one of the factors you got
to ask yourself do i want to continue to
be gone from where i would prefer to
live five months out of the year hmm
okay and so uh what are you hearing
about mcvay is it like uh is it espn is
it
amazon could it be fox if amazon takes
troy aikman i mean that's there's a ton
of chatter on that front what do you
think what are you learning about
marshawn of the new york post reported
in the days before the super bowl that
espn would be interested if mcveigh
leaves and i think the problem with that
is espn's got to make him interested to
leave he's not going to do the sean
payton and walk away and then say i'm
here for anybody who's hiring he's not
going to walk away unless he's got the
two in the bush right ready to go
he's not going to quit his job
uh without knowing that someone's going
to pay whatever it is and i think part
of it too is convincing the network that
he's in it for more than a year or two i
think one of the misgivings teams or
networks will have about sean payton
is uh you know we don't want a guy
that's going to do it for a year and
then go coach the cowboys we want
somebody who's doing it for the long
haul and mcvay you know he could do it
for 10 or 15 years
and and still come back and coach and
pursue a second super bowl with a
different team 15 years from now when
he's only 51 it's amazing to think that
he could spend that much time in tv and
swing back around later almost like what
dick vermeel did during you know he had
that long long break where we never
thought he was going to come back and he
came back and coached the rams and then
won a super bowl and walked away just
like mcvay may do but it's in it's it's
it's in the court now of whoever is
willing to do it espn amazon
fox
we know the money's out there
and uh it's significant and it keeps
getting more and more significant and uh
you know if it's a leverage play by
mcveigh good for him somebody's got to
squeeze the oligarchs to pay more money
the coaches when you look at how player
payroll has gone up over the past 50
years they've managed to keep the
coaches from making what they should get
and any coach that has the kind of of
leverage that mcveigh has should use it
mike florio pro football talk on peacock
and then of course online and and
digital everywhere social right here on
the rich eisen show so um
so many stories throughout the super
bowl week outside
of the game uh i saw your post last week
about stephen ross and the dolphins and
what the league is
looking into about brian flores's
allegation of
getting six figures to lose football
games the minute he was hired by the
dolphins what do you know right now what
can you tell me well i know that there's
a belief the nfl is going to be able to
prove that
ross made the offer and there was a
report
right in the aftermath of the flores
lawsuit it was an nfl network report
from cameron wolfe that there's an
unnamed witness who heard
ross say what he said
and
i'm already starting to get the sense
that ross is going to try to claim he
was joking i don't understand what the
joke would be i don't know where the
punch line would reside i know comedy is
hard but i don't i just don't get it and
it would be along the lines of getting
on an airplane and joking about having a
bomb in your carry-on i think it's just
something the nfl doesn't want people
joking about they don't want to
legitimize the tanking reality the
tanking temptation in any way shape or
form so he's got a problem and i think
if the walls this is just speculation on
my part but he's got bruce beal lined up
to
take over the team when ross
steps aside and ross said two years ago
he's not going to sell out his interest
in his lifetime well if the walls start
closing in i could see ross doing what
jerry richardson did in 2017 and just
cashing out and moving on that wouldn't
surprise me daniel snyder on the other
hand i'm sure we're going to talk about
him i think he fights and scratches and
claws and never gives up and never
surrenders and keeps it tied up in court
as long as he can but i think if ross
gets the the talking to from
you know people he respects in league
circles that this is not going to go
well i i won't be surprised if he just
cashes out and moves on so flores has
receipts he literally has a receipt
of this uh offer i don't know if he's
got it in writing but it sounds like
there's going to be a witness and and
the other thing ross has to worry about
if he forces them to do a full-blown
investigation that creates evidence
an ambitious prosecutor could very
easily indict him under the sports
bribery act which is as plain as it can
be it's very broad but it's very plain
and it's very simple you put yourself in
position to go away for up to five years
not that ross would ever have to do time
but that's not how you want to exit
public life when you're on the wrong
side of 80 under the cloud of an
indictment for violation of the sports
bribery act so the nfl is going to take
it seriously and i suspect that if they
just get enough
this is again this is kind of educated
speculation
i think they just go to him and and say
you don't want us
to do this you don't want us to do this
full-blown investigation you don't want
us making the prosecutor's case
for that prosecutor you just want this
to go away wow mike florio here on the
rich eisen show and another one that
that's consumed much of the week and
still is right now i'll just ask it
point blank what the hell is happening
with kyler murray what happened when
what is going on that's a great question
and
something caused him to strip the
cardinals from his social media
platforms the day after the pro bowl see
i think he went to the pro bowl
and somebody said something that got him
thinking about something you know the
possibility of playing for a different
team playing in a different location
being a tom brady or matthew stafford
picking his next shot
uh and it may have been a manifestation
of frustration about the support or lack
thereof that he has around him and then
it goes next level with chris mortensen
reporting on sunday yeah how about that
yeah and i you know i i've said this a
few times so i guess i shouldn't measure
my words carefully now i'm uncomfortable
and i i did not
get a journalism degree i never went to
journalism school but through 20 years
i've kind of learned
where the hot button topics are and
where you can get yourself into trouble
sharing an opinion like that selfish
self-centered immature and
finger-pointing with unnamed sources
backing it up
that makes me uncomfortable because
there's surely people who don't believe
that there are surely people who
interact with tyler murray who believe
that he's exactly what he needs to be
for a 24 year old franchise quarterback
and look at some of the other
quarterbacks around the nfl when things
aren't going their way they become
self-centered immature and
finger-pointing too i mean tom brady
slapping around the microsoft surface
and getting in people's faces when
things aren't going his way and he's
admitted he doesn't handle those
situations well i mean kyle murray has
gone through crap the last three years
in arizona compared to what he dealt
with in high school in college where he
lost a grand total of three games right
at both levels combined so
i it's it's awkward it's weird
and that's somebody i didn't tell them
somebody had to tell him that right
somebody had to tell mort that and then
somebody from his side told mort you
know that that uh kyler feels he's being
scapegoated and i'm i'm just wondering
where where all of this came
from right like where
obviously it came from other people but
but that there there is a description of
clearly something's up and then murray
calls what we're talking about the mort
stuff nonsense when the nonsense became
public
when he
scrubbed his instagram account like like
like a spurned high school sweetheart
you know what i'm saying and
and i i kind of don't understand like
where it goes right
because unless it goes to a i demand to
get out of here the cardinals have him
contractually
uh in the fold for what at least two
more years right and then and then yeah
franchise tags after that so what what's
it about like not getting the josh allen
deal right now do you think is that what
it is
for it to come up so quickly if it's
contractual in any way shape or form for
it to come up so quickly right the most
reasonable explanation is he has told
the team i'm ready to do a contract and
they've said we want to wait a year that
would be because why you wouldn't be at
a point where you'd be at the kind of
impasse where you would act out in in
early february it wouldn't be it's too
early right it's too soon it would be
along the lines of hey i'm ready to go
and they're like well you know what you
had the injury and you know we want to
give it one more year and see where it
goes from here and almost like the baker
mayfield situation or the lamar jackson
although that's different dynamics with
jackson but i think that that it's
possible if it's contractual kyler's
ready to get his reward and they're not
ready to give it to him or it could just
be he's sick of losing but but surely
he's seen enough in three years in the
nfl to know
that you're not gonna go
15 and two you're not going to dominate
you're going to have to scratch and claw
and fight and i don't know what other
team he would want to play for unless
you know there was there was some stuff
about mike evans and
you know does he want to go to the
buccaneers i don't know i sure feel like
the bucks are going to be looking for
one of these other guys whether it's
deshawn watson or or russell wilson i
know ian rappaport mentioned those two
as possibilities for the buccaneers to
trade and replace tom brady but
maybe maybe kyla murray's in play and i
don't you know even though i'm
uncomfortable with that that
opinion driven anonymous report
if it if it came from michael bidwell or
somebody close to bidwell then
you have to wonder if they're reaching
the point where they're ready to make a
change which is stunning because he's
the guy he was he was their guy he was
the guy they had to have they threw josh
rosen overboard to get him in 2019. it
would be amazing if they have a divorce
after only three years and he's also
supremely talented you know i mean and
and whatever caused the late season
collapse for three straight years
clearly he has a role in it but not the
sole role in it you know and and
having de'andre hopkins is not a bad
target to have i mean
that be that as it may i mean he's got
the ultimate leverage too rich he's the
only guy in the nfl that can say i don't
need football i can go play another
professional sport right this is this
would be the very wrong time to pull
that lever though when
japan is the only option you know and
you and i have been through you and i
you and i have been through the uh labor
wars you see when they call for uh
federal help you know and your
management that doesn't look good you
know and and then it's rejected by the
union i don't even want to go there
that's how i lost all my hair mike
florio here on the rich eisen show you
mentioned desean watson moments ago how
viable is this i mean what is going on
with him where all of a sudden now we're
reporting about
his wish list when there's so much other
things stuff you know situations is our
catchphrases in the sports world uh
hanging over him what's going on with
him yeah we've got the criminal
investigation that has not yet resulted
in a grand jury completing its work
there was an expectation that that would
be done the end of january here we are
halfway through february and it's not
done there are 22 pending civil cases
and there was an effort to settle those
to facilitate the trade to the dolphins
18 of the women were ready to go four of
them held out and that's what kept it
from happening
and now the window's open
for him to be
questioned under oath as part of these
lawsuits too so he just needs to make it
all go away and i don't mean that in a
flippant way or just you know write a
check but that's how justice gets
dispensed in the civil system you sue
someone
for an award of monetary damages so if
if he can make these 22 individuals feel
good about the outcome and uh and move
on and get closure he needs to do it the
problem is
from the lawyer's perspective
the fact that watson needs these cases
to be resolved increases the value of
the settlement sometimes a settlement is
driven by you know how much money
someone lost
when something happened or whatever
their emotional distress was the jury
has to figure that out sometimes the
value comes from what it means to the
defendant for this thing to go away and
that that drives the price up and at
some point watson's just got to accept
it and write the check and move on
unless there's one person who's like uh
he
we waited all this time to get him
deposed and under oath damn straight
we're gonna do that you know like that
that could be happening too right
especially after
most of the
people suing him have already had to go
through their
uh inherently unpleasant experience of
being grilled under oath by
by someone from rusty hardin's law firm
if not harden himself yeah that's part
of it too it's like hey i want to sit
there while he has to answer these
questions and and maybe if he has to go
through the process of being grilled by
tony busby for eight hours on a
wednesday afternoon at tony busby's law
office
maybe that's part of the
the process that's needed to get these
folks to the point where they're willing
to resolve the case and move on this is
part of the closure it's part of the
justice it's a very loose rough process
it doesn't always have to be a verdict
returned by a jury there are other ways
to get people to feel like they've
gotten their justice and but there's
also a clock ticking with a new league
year that begins right and teams are
going to have to know
i i imagine quarterback carousel is
already going to start spinning i mean
it was january 30 last year with matthew
stafford got traded to the rams
unofficially right so you know i think
aaron rodgers is the guy that is the
first domino this year but
yeah the you know the the teams that
watson may be interested in playing for
may make other arrangements and make it
impractical for watson this year and the
stakes are high for the texans they own
35 million fully guaranteed last year it
was 10. this year it's 35 million in
salary they need to get this thing done
and they need to move on from him wow
that's all at play right i mean and
that's all at play in the next month
aaron rodgers says that he's going to
make a decision sooner rather than later
that's in the next month
who else is in the next month russell
wilson in the next month um the eagles
can obviously sit back and wait to see
how it all shakes out because they got
three first-rounders coming up in the
draft um other times
right in play now
not the net i i think the more
fascinating part of that is what do the
colts do right not where does once go
because i don't know that anyone's going
to want him especially to walk in the
door as a starter right but what do the
colts do to replace carson wentz because
that's a pretty attractive team good
offensive line jonathan taylor decent
receivers potent defense
you know if i'm aaron i don't know i
don't know aaron rodgers in indianapolis
i don't know that could be the premise
of a sitcom maybe but um
but
you know there are there are uh worst
places he could go in the afc well the
one thing i'm thinking about is why not
the titans what you know what i know i
know
they're buying a house in
franklin tennessee right
they say they're all in with ryan
tannehill it's easy to say that if aaron
rodgers isn't knocking on your door
saying let me in i think it changes if
you know aaron aaron rodgers wants to
play for you and then the last one for
you is the brady right if he lurks and
he sits and and and um what is what is
happening there is are we all just
reading into the the vacuum now that he
is created by opening the door slightly
ajar with the never saying ever or or
what what do you think well mike i i saw
that greg allman of the athletic
reported that he's either going to come
back to the buccaneers or retire that
he's not going to try to finagle his way
to another team but as a practical
matter if the buccaneers go out and fill
that seat with a veteran who is pricey
and they give up draft capital to get
that guy
if he comes back after that they're not
going to keep both of them
he he's necessarily going to go
somewhere else i believe
yeah the question that gets raised all
the time what else does he have to prove
what else does he have to accomplish
well he's never played for the 49ers the
team that he rooted for growing up and
we know two years ago that was his first
choice and they didn't want him and if
i'm the 49ers my choices are jimmy
garoppolo trey lance or tom brady for
2022 and i want to win the super bowl in
2022 i'm going with tom brady
and lance just waits and garoppolo goes
somewhere and this yeah and lance
atlanta sits for two years
i think there's i wouldn't be shocked if
they just keep garoppolo if they don't
get another because no i don't think
that they believe lance is ready and i
think they went into this knowing that
we may have to sit him for two years i
know that's possible but i think they're
done with jimmy g and i think that that
i i think that that is done and they're
going to try and figure out over the
next three to four weeks where to send
him there are so many other teams out
there that are quarterback needy or
could be i
i don't know just sticking with lance
and then getting a veteran to back him
up and if brady suddenly raises his hand
and goes you know what i just think it
would be a nice way to finish everything
up um you know be around mom and dad and
and be where it used to be and walk off
into the sunset maybe
with a trophy one with the t he was
there for the catch game if you haven't
heard that a thousand times and uh you
know
that that's the one thing that he hasn't
accomplished yet that would still be on
his football bucket list oh my god what
a great few months this is going to be
and you know what rich it started with
brady two years ago but all of a sudden
the football hot stove thing
is quarterback driven and it was never
that way teams would never get rid of a
quarterback that they thought was good
enough for fear of regressing now you
got teams willing to flip these guys and
get rid of them and bring this guy in
and we're going to go for it and you
know when you see tom brady and matthew
stafford change teams and win super
bowls their first year it validates the
approach brother the next style
evolution of that is somebody drafting a
kid and and and then
trying to win a super bowl in his first
four or five years of contractual
control and instead of signing him to a
nine-figure deal just flipping him and
starting again baker mayfield that might
be it right that might be it yep oh my
gosh thanks for the call mike i always
appreciate it take care man playmaker is
available in three weeks and six days
but right now as well where all books
are sold hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here